[Musik]
leider mila dann kandidaten aus
was wir hier erleben ist die geburt
eines neuen ägyptens eines freien
ägyptens ich mohamed muss sie stehe vor
euch um euch zu huldigen
endlich waren die muslimbrüder am ziel
am 29 juni 2012 schwur mohammed mursi
auf dem symbol beladenen tahrir-platz
den ägyptern ewige treue
als frisch gewählte präsident
[Musik]
die muslimbrüder wenden sich am anfang
es war zur selben zeit als sich der
junge schweizer historiker viktor willi
in die welt der muslimbrüder begaben
die meisten islamisten redet aber
muslime daran und ich war nicht so
richtig vorstellen dass das eines ist
mir zentralisiert man zu den 100
wir haben das einfach fragt wer sind
eigentlich die muss neben brühl tätig
und erzählen was sind das für leute
erwartet die
[Musik]
und so für victor balli nach kairo und
landete mitten im strudel der geschichte
[Musik]
der historiker wiegt oder willi hat
arabisch gelernt über die muslimbrüder
soll jetzt eine doktorarbeit für die
universität oxford stehen diese politik
vorbereite
die haben mir aber leid was ich sonst
themenausstellung eine wand ist aber und
das ist der politische islam
die islamistische bewegung und die
wichtigste und dann habe ich meine fans
haben
[Musik]
in ihrer über 80-jährigen geschichte
waren die muslimbrüder oft verboten
wurden sie verfolgt und verhaftet
von einem jahr aber die wanderer
muslimbrüder mohammed mursi
die ersten freien und halbwegs fairen
präsidentschaftswahlen in der geschichte
ägyptens nach dem langzeit herrscher
mubarak vom thron gestoßen worden war
heute ist die stimmung in ägypten
angespannt
lucie ist bereits wieder geschichte
soeben hat der prozess gegen den
ehemaligen präsidenten begonnen
viktor willi taucht ein in die straßen
kairos
eine mehrzahl hier steht hinter der
armee und ist gegen die muslimbrüder von
einem straßencafé laden ihn die leute
ein mit ihnen zu diskutieren dürfen wir
finden
ja klar kommt setzt sich zu uns wir
machen einen film über ägypten nach dem
militärcoup was militärcoup das war kein
ko das war eine revolution eine
revolution ja eine revolution wenn du es
einen grünen kannst du gleich wieder
verschwinden wie immer wenn ausländer in
ägypten firmen kommt es sofort zu einem
kleinen aufschlag nur sie hat viel
versprochen aber nichts getan und was
ist mit all jenen die während der
revolution starben
immer mehr beginnen sich einzumischen
moment ich erklär kurz etwas fürs
schweizer fernsehen
[Musik]
dafür dreht aber bitte nicht was ich
sage
die leute sind misstrauisch ich bin
schweizer
wir sind extrem neutral dich sehe ich
mit dir habe ich kein problem aber wie
kann ich sicher sein dass sie sendet was
wir sagen nicht alles verdreht
die stimmung wird langsam feindlich und
dann taucht im hintergrund die polizei
verrückt ist fertig mit filmen
kaum haben wir also begonnen droht das
vorhaben schon zu scheitern
was ist überhaupt noch möglich
herauszufinden was sind die ägypter noch
bereit preiszugeben
und über allem die frage wie konnte es
soweit kommen
viktor willi will einen ehemaligen
muslimbruder besuchen
begleitet wird er von sarah ramadan
fast alle treffen zu denen will fährt
hat sie ermöglicht die ägyptische
journalistin ist seine engste vertraute
in kairo
[Musik]
willi trifft ahmed bahn war 20 jahre
lang ein muslimbruder vor zwei jahren
trat er aus der bruderschaft aus weil er
deren machtstreben nicht mehr ertrug
[Musik]
die muslimbrüder waren so stark weil sie
sich um die armen kümmert weil sie
soziale arbeit leistet in ägypten waren
die muslimbrüder an der macht angekommen
doch gemäss ihrer ideologie sollte das
erst der anfang sein
zuerst wollen die muslimbrüder den
menschen zum guten muslimen machen dann
die familie an die gesellschaft dann
kommt ein muslimische regierung ein
muslimischer staat dann das kalifat und
am ende die herrschaft über die ganze
welt was für uns in europa so bedrohlich
klingt ist auch für willi schwer zu
fassen
wir sind bei ihm zu hause auf seinem
balkon seinem studierzimmer dieses
kalifat das ziel der muslimbrüder ist
ein äußerst schwammiger begriff was sie
sich vorstellen wird ist recht diffus
ist auch wo mir nicht wirklich traurig
und habe ihnen so behandelt und was ich
gehört habe ist dass wir eine
europäische union oder united states of
islam mit gemeinsamen weg gemeinsamer
wirtschaftsraum
gemeinsame politik quasi und einer
spirituellen führer gefangen al khali um
die ideen der muslimbrüder besser zu
verstehen suchen viktor willi und sarah
ramadan auf dem büchermarkt nach alten
schriften willi will herausfinden auf
welche stellen im koran sich die
muslimbrüder berufen wenn sie auf ihren
allumfassenden anspruch tauchen
sind das sind ja das ist zwar richtig
endlich die tiere effektiver zeit fand
ich meine schoner gut die leute und das
neue demokratisch und jemand eine hockey
und der hat seine berechtigung seiten
alles böse ist nochmals terrorist und 21
inzwischen beginnt sich willis bild von
den muslimbrüdern zu schärfen 500
persönlich das fehlen der börse ist eine
sehr nette gold die man zu sehen würde
man schaut aber die werft effektiv in
die irre geführt oder vor dem vor der
affäre und die führung hat ihn sehr
stark ideologisch die weltanschauung und
und mit den dingen meditiert der basis
der eigenen geschäft
sarah ramadan gefällt die zusammenarbeit
mit victor willi die journalistin der
staatlichen ägyptischen zeitung al ahram
recherchierte gerade zum verbleib der
bawag gelder in der schweiz als sich die
beiden kennenlernten
dieses buch wird speziell vor allem auch
weil wir beide aus unterschiedlichen
kulturen stammen mit unterschiedlichem
hintergrund ein mann und eine frau eine
muslima und an christ reckers
doktorarbeit soll auch wirklich tiefe
gehen
wir stützen uns weniger auf theorie als
vielmehr auf das was wir hier in ägypten
mit den muslimen denn erleben
[Musik]
das leben in ägypten war für viele
schwerer geworden unter der herrschaft
der brüder oder zumindest nicht besser
[Musik]
arbeit zu finden wurde immer schwieriger
das zusammenleben der religionen wurde
immer schwieriger die brotpreise stiegen
ist rothe weizen machen
[Musik]
vor den tankstellen bildeten sich lange
schlangen weil es kaum mehr benzin zu
geben schien
und auch die touristenorte blieben leer
die stimmung begann zu kippen
was hat man sie geleistet warte ab was
hat muss sie geleistet war ca die gräben
in der ägyptischen gesellschaft wurden
tiefer und tiefer
[Applaus]
um zu verstehen was zu diesem zeitpunkt
im innern der muslimbruderschaft
passierte besucht willi ein ehemaliges
führungsmitglied der brüder weil er
einen anderen kurs vertrat als die
führungsriege war kammerherr bari nach
der revolution aus der organisation
verstoßen worden
präsident muss sie versprach den
ägyptern innerhalb von 100 tagen die
größten probleme zu lösen
die unsicherheit das verkehrschaos die
abfallberge und die energieversorgung
kein einziges dieser probleme hatte
gelöst
im frühling dieses jahres begann eine
bewegung namens tarot das heißt so viel
wie rebellion unterschriften zusammen
gegen präsident musik
am 30 juni 2013 genau ein jahr nachdem
us präsident geworden war gingen
millionen ägypter auf die straße um
gegen ihn und die muslimbrüder zu
demonstrieren
[Applaus]
die muslime waren völlig überrascht als
sie die millionen auf den straßen sahen
und sie beschlossen ist dass photoshop
realität abzutun als etwas aufgebauscht
ist dort einfach nicht sein
[Applaus]
die armee stellte ein ultimatum sie gab
präsident muss sie 48 stunden zeit auf
die forderungen der demonstrierenden
einzugehen und neuwahlen anzusetzen
nur siege nicht auf das ultimatum ein
worauf die armee den präsidenten ab
setzte ihn verhaftete und damit die
regierungszeit der muslimbrüder
unter dem jubel der massen auf dem
tahrir platz nach genau einem jahr
beendete
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es war nochmals eine revolution eine
revolution gegen die korruption die sich
in die gesellschaft zu fressen bekommen
eine revolution gegen die rigiden
vorschriften der islamisten und eine
revolution gegen einen unfähigen
präsidenten für die muslimbrüder sehen
das anders
für sie ist es ein militär kugeligen
einen gewählten präsidenten den ganzen
heißen sommer über hatten sie in zwei
großen protest lagen aus diese lager
wurden zu symbolen de anhänger des
abgesetzten präsidenten bis armee und
polizei sie gewaltsam räumen
[Musik]
am 14 august 2013 starben an einem tag
mehr als 1000 menschen
[Musik]
rektor willi sucht den kontakt zu den
söhnen eines der ranghöchsten muslim
blutes der vater der zwillinge mohammed
und mahmut karim wurde nach der blutigen
räumung der protest lager verhaftet wie
fast die gesamte führungsriege der
bruderschaft die söhne haben ihren vater
erst vor zwei tagen im gefängnis besucht
sie haben meinen vater in eine
einzelzelle gesteckt ein meter breit
eineinhalb meter lang 18 tage lang
steckte in dieser winzigen zelle
die sonne hatte nie gesehen die
muslimbrüder sehen das was in ägypten
zurzeit geschieht als eine verschwörung
gegen sie alle aus unserer führungsriege
sind angeklagt gewalt angezettelt zu
haben aber wo sind die diese gewalt
ausgeübt haben sollen
die gibt es nicht weil wir gar nichts
gemacht haben die muslimbrüder als
harmlose opfer der geschichte oder sind
sie eben doch die ursache für den
strudel der gewalt in dem ägypten steckt
die neuen machthaber hatten angst
sie hatten angst dass die ägypter sehen
würden wer wir wirklich sind jeder der
dort war sah dass die muslimbrüder
friedlich und nette leute sind das macht
ihnen angst diese aussage ruft uns
unweigerlich die szene in erinnerung als
wir beim drehen abgeführt wurden
[Musik]
so langsam wird uns klar was an jedem
tag passiert war
die polizisten hatten uns auf den posten
geführt und uns deutlich gemacht dass es
keine gute idee sei weiter zu filmen
sonst könne es sein dass uns
irgendjemand alle knochen brechen könnte
sagte der offizier
dann ließen sie uns laufen
was zeigt ihnen was ist da passiert ist
ja sowas frauen ich gehe also ist doch
einfach auf die zweite vom militär als
auch b quasi innerhalb 24 stunden
zweimal baustraße laden und hieraus
gewinnt verschiedene interpretationen
oder also zum tathergang oder
miteinander und mit einer gut gerät und
die endlos filme und habe ich einer von
einer besorgten bürger polizei geholt
und nach siegen geführt wurde von der
polizei und kurz befragt worden und habe
viel mit einfach nehmen und es lustig
dass das nicht politisch aktiv sondern
eine folge ein besorgtes auf ein
normaler bürger und bleibt einfach
gemeinde mir sehr genau dosieren und
auto sehr harter kost im moment will
also sehr schlechtes bild verbreitet
peter und paul muslim brüder ist oder
und es zeigt einen weg sieht lee mit 65
69 faktor ist dass das sicherheitsstaat
wieder stärker präsent sonderfaktoren
wuchs zu wild mal traurig und das hat
die muslimbrüder effektiv waffen kommen
und und unserem headquarter also in
ihrem zentrum musik chancen haben was da
los gegangen ist und dreißigste juni und
ein dritter juli und so weiter und und
deshalb viele waffen im land sind oder
das macht die arbeit wird immer
schwieriger
ein muslimbruder nach dem anderen sagt
willi ab keiner ist mehr bereich vor der
kamera zu reden
jetzt dokumentarfilm zum auch hannover
also interview keine schonung auch mit
kameras schwierig und und ausländische
unternehmen an aufgerückte seniorencafé
viktor willi und sarah ramadan gehen
nochmals zum ehemaligen muslimbruder
ahmad bahn die muslimbrüder stehen vor
der größten herausforderung ihrer
geschichte
denn zum ersten mal werden sie in ihrem
kampf gegen das regime nicht mehr vom
volk unterstützt eine mehrheit der
ägypter wandte sich von den
muslimbrüdern ab weil sie sahen wohin
die vermischung von religion und politik
führt das ist vielleicht der vorteil der
kurzen herrschaften viele ägypter sehen
jetzt religion ist eines und politik
etwas anderes
das jahr von victor willi neigt sich dem
ende entgegen
die große frage ist hat es auch klarheit
gebracht
klarheit brachten sich aber sie sagen
mir wir ja 61 ist frustrierend aber sich
nur so lange vom steuern verlangen der
besuch ist aber es ist eigentlich schön
sowieso nichts gelernt was man muss
loslassen von rossmann behaupten
interessant werde ich mal einfach
irgendwo man so richtig hätte dies aus
dem einem computerspiel ist meine
adventure game ruine so fremd störend
ist und überall wieder disco kost und
und es grundlegende informationen
passiert alles auch immer unklar war
und das ist eigentlich habe dies führt
zu hause das grundprinzip von der
ignoranz vor augen will sich stärker auf
das vom westen oder heute der beste für
wissenschaften hat mein stil ist alles
punkte schlüssel einfach überhaupt nicht
meine süße aber müssten tomaten diese
charta ist zum beispiel zeit aktionisten
fliehen vorteil will er wusste dass er
nicht weiß
während die andere ecke meine 12 und auf
bestellung mit kfz schon sokrates und es
gibt kein zurück das ist immer noch ein
die geschichte der muslimbrüder wird
noch viele wendungen nehmen
sein buch wird victor willi trotzdem
schreiben
[Musik]